I'm Shaquita Williams and I played
soccer with actor Boris kojo soccer huh
yeah when was this in 2017. and what's
the circumstance were you were you in a
league or it was like a corporate team
okay yeah I worked with a um a small
production company and we were producing
a movie of his and his movie was in post
I got to work with him a bit and then he
joined us for a game of soccer on our
corporate team so explain to me the
corporate team I don't what Corporation
well it's a corporate team we were in a
corporation we went through this company
that likes
companies to play against each other so
it was sort of sort of like a league
then yeah okay and they just let this
guy this hulking perfect specimen of
masculinity just walk onto a team
basically yeah we had an extra shirt